Soldiers in Yemen somberly march in the National Day parade...
...one day after a suicide bomber killed at least 96 troops.
In Syria, a bomb explodes in a Damascus restaurant, killing five people.
A train crash in southern India kills at least 25 and injures dozens more.
In Italy, firemen rescue art from churches...
...hit by a strong earthquake in the Emilia-Romagna region.
In the US, a privately owned company launches a rocket...
...on a mission to the International Space Station,...
...where no private company has ever gone before.
In Japan, Tokyo Skytree, the world's tallest broadcast tower...
...and second tallest building, opens to the general public.